في دور غريب ومختلف وجديد بيطل الفنانه
اللبناني طوني عيسى في الموسم الرمضاني
بشخصيه زكريا في مسلسل النار بالنار طوني
بيكون في المسلسل المتطرف وصاحب فكر داعشي
متزوج من قاصر وبيصنع متفجرات وبيتعاون مع
جماعات مسلحه وهذه الدور ما بيشبه اي دور
عملوا طوني من قبل لانه حقيقه طالع مستفز
جدا وحتى هو قال انه في كثير ناس كرهوه
بسبب زكريا
الي مصلحه بهيدا هاي من بابه لمحرابه
خير زكريا
خذ رجالك وانقلع من الحي انت بالزيت سدوا
لبوظه
معاه حق تعليقات الناس الكارهه لشخصيه
زكريا ماليه المنصات هذا غير تعليقات
هائله عن اداء رائع في المسلسل
ومن بيروت ينضم الينا الفنان طوني عيسى
اهلا فيك معنا طوني وخليني اول طبعا
السلام امانه نقول لك سلام زميلتنا ميسون
نواهض بتسلم عليك كثير السلام وهلكتنا من
قبل الحلقه وهي جلسه بتشيد فيكم وفي ادائك
في المسلسل بس يبدو في اتفاق عام اصلا على
هذا الموضوع حتى على منصات التواصل
طبعا شكرا اول شيء للاستضافه كتير سعيد
وان شاء الله بتكون الحلقه حلوه
يعني توني خليني اقول لك انه على قد ما
الناس كارهه الشخصيه على قد ما بيتكلموا
على ادائك انه شيء جدا مختلف بس كمان
المسلسل اصلا جدلي انت لما جالك الورق
وقريته ما تخوفت من الموضوع
الصراحه لا ما تخوفت لانه
نحن كممثلين علينا ننقل واقع
حدث معين شخصيه معينه
لازم نكون عم نعطي الحقيقه لازم نكون عم
نضوي على امور مرقت معنا
من الماضي مش غلط انه نضوي عليها بشكل انه
ما تكون جدا مستفزه او فيها اذا بدك تعدي
على او على احد او على شيء او على بلد
بالعكس هيدي امور مرقت بحياتنا
الوصايه وبزمن كذا كذا
ولدتوا كثير اشياء ومن ضمنها هيدا المسلسل
عم يشرح بعض الافكار عنا مش غلط طبعا
يعني هو فعلا كثير ناس اتكلموا انه لاول
مره بيشوفوا كلام ومشاهد فعلا هذا اللي
بيصير في الشارع بيكون والنقاشات اللي
بتدور مسلسل جريء جدا ايوا المشاهد اللي
بتدور بين خانه الجراه بتندفن خصوصا
المشاهد انه بين السوريين
اللبنانيين والكلام هذا كله بس كمان بنفس
الوقت في ناس قالوا انه يعني يا جماعه
كفايه اثاره للاعراض بين الشعبين كيف بتحس
انت بتحس على او بترد على هذا النقد
اثاره للنهارات بالعكس نحن اذا الانسان
هالقد ضعيف وميال لامور سيئه او يرجع
للماضي وما بيسكر باب هو هيدا حر هو حر
بدنا هذا رايه الشخصي نحن بنهرب منه
الاشخاص فنحن عم نضوي على حقبه مثل اي
حقبه بتاريخ ليش ما بيزعلوا الاتراك لما
بيزعلوا الفرنساويه منها لا بيزعل كتير
ناس منه
فهيدي حاله طبيعيه مرقت بالتاريخ وعم
بتدور عليها شيء طبيعي بعدين هي قصه مسلسل
منه شي على ارض الواقع او عن جد هذا الشيء
عم بصير او عن جد عم بصير في ايه يعني من
طرف لا طرف اخر هيدا كله تمثيل
وحلو نشوف وحلو نشوف شيء جديد
ملينا من التكرار صراحه
مبني على لو اساس يعني انتوا ما انتم
جايبينه من الفراغ
طبعا
طيب لو مثلا نقلتك على دورك انت شخصيا
يعني طوني انت بتلعب دور متطرف وهذا
المتطرف من دين غير دينك وممكن بعض الناس
ياخذوا هذا الموضوع بحساسيه ما وترك هذا
الموضوع
الموضوع جدلي جدا
فيك توصي فيه اقصى الحدود وتبعديات ما بدك
بس بكتسب عندك انه كمان برجع لك لموضوع
التمثيل اليوم زكريا في كثير منه يعني في
اشخاص
متدينين بالشكل
بالظاهر هن متدينين لكن
بالعمق اني لا مثل ما عم نشوف حاله زكريا
زكريا زي بده يعمل فتنه بالحيه زكريا
استولى على الحية جاي يخلف العالم ببعضها
زكريا منه طبيعي هذا الانسان منو طبيعي
وكم هناك من اشخاص غير طبيعيين في الحياه
يعني بنظام الحاجات ككل
فهذه الحاله الاستثنا هي موجوده بارض
الواقع
ولا التصور هي من ارض الواقع اذا عشق
الديني بتقولي لي مثلا عند المسيحيين ما
في الاسلام في او لا ما بروح لعليا لانه
ما في انسان فوق راسه خيمه في كثير ناس
عنده الطرفين هيك وهيك
عرفت علي هيدي الشخصيه عم تتجسد لانه
في تطرف وشخصيات سيئه في اي دين لانه
بالاونه الاخيره كنا عم نسمع انه في
متطرفين عم عم يعني في خلل بمطرح
وهيدا واحد من المخللين
عرفتي قرات بس انت التعليقات اللي بتعلق
على هذا الموضوع
البعض منها مشكل بس ما كان سبب لك انك
مثلا تعيد التفكير في الدور او شيء انت
تعاملت معاه كدور وكشخصيه موجوده وخلاص هو
هو دور وشخصيه موجوده ونقطع على السطر
ما توجهنا ولا ولا اذا بدك كنا عملتهم
بحدا بالشخص او عم بنقول عم عم يعني عم
نهين لا ابدا هذا الشخصيه عم تتمثل بدور
هالقد بحجمها طيب خليني كمان انقلك للبوست
انت كتبت بوست عن او بتوجه فيه يعني زي
جمله خليه بس يظهر معنا الان على الشاشه
هذا البوست اللي انت كاتبه وبترد انه في
على المغرضين واللي بيحطوا كلام على لسانك
وانه كل الاحترام والتقدير للممثلين
السوريين وما الى ذلك ايش صار اللي خلاك
توني تكتب هذا البوست
ايش صار اللي صار صرت احكي مثلي
اللي صاروا من بعض شويه
حبيبتي
قلنا الشرف اللي صار هو انه صار في كلام
كتب كلام عن لساني انا مش قاله يعني
بكل مقابلات اللي مرقت فيها بهالفتره
الاخيره ولا مره انا جرحت ولا مره قلت انا
يا ريتني الممثلين السوريين عم بياخدوا من
تربه عم بياخدوا من دربي عم بياخدوا ادوار
البطوله ولا مره قلتها من زمان كان في
موضوع معين وخلص وانتهى وخلص الموضوع بس
اليوم نحنا باحسن حال مع الممثلين
السوريين ونحن وياهم واحد وعم نشتغل بكل
المسلسلات المشتركه وكثير مبسوطين واحترام
واحد خليني خليني اكمل
عود الاشخاص مغرديا اللي عم بيحكوا يعني
عم بيقونوني
اقوال انا مني اي لا
هل انا بستحق اكون عم باخد ادوار بطوله او
بياخد ادوار بغير مسلسلات وبغير دول هذا
الشيء تاني بس شق انه انه هن عم ياخدوا من
دربي انا ما قلتها واللي عم بيقول يعني
عنده مشكله مع اوكي يعني
لما انت بتقول انه لا كل الامور تمام لا
هو في ازمه حاليا موجوده انه فعلا الدراما
المشتركه هي اللي منتشره فعلا في تراجع
تام للمسلسلات اللبنانيه المسلسل او
الممثل اللبناني البطوله دائما للممثل
السوري
نعم
شوفي
نحن اليوم طلعنا بمسلسل
العين بالعين قبل
سيرين عبد النور
وعمل نتيجه كمان المسلسل كتير قويه
مسلسلات كمان فيها ابطال سوريين شباب وعم
تشوفي ابطال لبنانيه
كمان عم بيكونوا قد الحمل وزياده
هلا بتقولي لي مثلا ليش عم بيكون البطل
سوريا او البطل اللبنانيه هذا بصير
محطه بتنقي الاشخاص شركه شركه انتاج عم
تختار هذا الشيء ممكن
هذا الشيء بساعدهم اكثر
[موسيقى]
الكامل طبعا بس انه لا يخلو الامر من انه
نحن عم نكون عم نشارك وعم نشارك وعم نكون
فعالين بالمسلسلات الاشخاص اللي عم بتشارك
اوكي في في اذا بدك السنه ما شفنا ابطال
لبنانيين عم يشتغلوا ما شفنا ممثلين السنه
للاسف وانا بزعل انا من لبناني والممثلين
اللبنا
اخواتنا
واصحابنا ورفقاتنا واكلنا وشو بدنا سوا
واشتغلنا سوا وبنعرف قدوريتهم
وبنعرفوا
كان في غياب شبه كبير
للدراما اللبنانيه او للممثلين اللبنانيين
طيب نحن على العموم بنشكرك على هذه
المداخلاتوني بالتوفيق انت مكسر الدنيا
فعلا النار بالنار مكسره الدنيا بشكل عام
ودورك كمان عامل الكثير من
الجدل وكمان طبعا المديح على اداءك شكرا
لك نورتنا اليوم كان معنا من بيروت الفنان
طوني عيسى شكرا لك
[موسيقى]